good afternoon and welcome to the
National Press Club my name is Monroe
Carmen I'm president of the club and
editor-at-large at Bloomberg Business
News I'd like to welcome Club members
and their guests in the audience excuse
me as well as those of you watching on
c-span or listening to this program on
National Public Radio or the global
internet computer network before
introducing our head table I would like
to mention some of our upcoming speakers
on Thursday tomorrow the 27th Reed Hundt
chairman of the Federal Communications
Commission will discuss violence on
television in the speech entitled
television or telev Islands on Friday
excuse me July 28th Secretary of State
Warren Christopher will deliver a major
policy address on Asia and on Monday
August 7th actor Martin Sheehan will
address a press club audience
transcripts and audio and videotapes of
Press Club luncheons are available by
calling 1-800 NPC two three three four
one eight hundred and PC two three three
four if you have questions for our
speaker please write them on the cards
provided at your table and I will ask as
many as time permits I'd not like to
introduce our head table guests and ask
them to stand briefly when their names
are called from your right Jim asker of
Aviation Week and space technology
Maria ratio of the Fort Worth
star-telegram
you can hold your applause till the end
I'm sure they wouldn't mind Paul
Hubbardston of USA Today sorry Paul I
deprived over Marilyn love a wife of Jim
Lovell
Kathy Kylie of the Arkansas
democrat-gazette
I'll skip over our speakers with a
moment Mark Johnson over here general
immediate general news service and
chairman of the National Press Club
speakers committee nothing Colin Hanks
son of somebody here Dan Carney
freelance journalist and member of the
speaker's committee who arranged today's
luncheon thank you very much Dan
Patricia Williams of space news Jeff
Kluger co-author of the book lost moon
that provided them a script for the
movie Apollo 13
Craig Hines watching bureau chief
Houston Chronicle and Brooks Bullock
Washington bureau chief of The Hollywood
Reporter
our guest speaker today is actually two
people Jim Lovell is the astronaut who
commanded the ill-fated yet heroic
mission to the moon in 1970 Tom
Tom Hanks is the actor who plays Jim
Lovell in this summer smash hit movie
Apollo 13
as the films narration points out Apollo
13 was the most successful failure in
the history of manned spaceflight the
explosion of an onboard oxygen oxygen
tent prevented the mission from
achieving its objective of landing on
the moon however with the help of the
NASA team mr. Lovell and two fellow
astronauts overcame incredible odds to
manage a safe return to earth for five
days
life on Earth came to a virtual
standstill as television networks that
had offered a collective yarn as the
launch of Apollo 13 then began to
pre-amp regular programming to report on
how the troubled mission was fairing
while mr. Lovell will be best remembered
for his Apollo 13 adventure he actually
completed four missions into space in
all two with the Gemini program and two
with Apollo his early missions help
develop the docking techniques that
would be crucial in the eventual landing
on the moon it is my pleasure to inform
you all today that the White House is
announcing this afternoon that President
Clinton is awarding the ninth
congressional space medal of honor to
James a Louisville
for his and I quote contributions to the
welfare of the nation and to all
humanity unquote I'll read a portion of
the citation quote as one of our early
pioneers in space mr. Lovell piloted
both the Gemini 7 and the Gemini 12
missions Gemini 7 included the first
rendezvous of two human control
maneuverable spacecraft mr. Lovell
served as command module pilot on Apollo
8 humankind's maiden voyage to the moon
and the crew became the first humans to
leave the Earth's gravitational
influence Apollo 13 launched in 1970
proved the program's ability to weather
a major crisis and bring the crew back
home safely end of quote from the
citation for all his exploits in outer
space however one of Mr Lovells most
important decisions was made right here
on earth after Hollywood bought the
rights to his story play you in the
movie without hesitation mr. Lovell
replied Kevin Costner
mr. Kosta wasn't available so Hollywood
had to turn to a second choice and
obscure an obscure active site Orion and
obscure an obscure actor named Tom Hanks
Tom who Tom Hanks
seriously though after his stellar
performances in the movies Philadelphia
and Forrest Gump
mr. Hanks now stands a good chance of
becoming the first person ever to win
three best ask Best Actor Oscars in a
row for his impersonation of Kevin
Costner playing jammed
if mr. Hanks wasn't the first name to
come to mr. Lovins mind the actor
quickly won the astronaut over with his
enthusiasm for the role mr. Hanks long
has harbored a fascination with outer
space and astronauts when he first met
Jim Lovell it was Tom Hanks who was
asking for autographs today our two
guests will share their thoughts on the
Apollo 13 mission in reality and in the
movies and on the future of space
exploration now before we begin I ask
the photographer's please stay back
cause we don't have that much time left
first warm welcome for mr. Tom Hanks who
will make some remarks and then
introduce Jim Lovell thank you very much
thank you thank you very much
boy it's never too late to get back on
that old celebrity mule train and just
push a movie you know four weeks after
release you can always work in another
press stop no prob you know if Kevin
Costner had played Jim Lovell which it
still would have been a wonderful movie
because I still would have been in it I
would have done whatever was necessary
to play Fred Hayes and I would have done
a fine job in that role as well I would
have played a mr. quiet astronaut though
Jim I'm not quite what Bill Paxton did
now because because I was so inspired by
the space program as a young man because
I was of that age where the the space
program was held up as the perfect
example of everything America was
supposed to be as well as a great lesson
for any child to pay attention to in
school that was part physics it was part
government it was part science but it
was also part art and inspiration just
by the very fact that we were deciding
to hurl men into the the unforgiving
vacuum and yet the same time glorious
freefall of outer space
I have always harbored a great
fascination for the space program and I
was up on all of the Apollo program
I knew the crews I knew the flights and
I knew the mission goals as they were
stated and I was in fact very much
involved in the drama that went on with
Apollo 13 I woke up in the morning and
read the headline in the San Francisco
Chronicle on the 14th of April in 1970
and saw that the the mission was in
danger I ran home from Bret Hart Junior
High School in Oakland California to
watch Jules Bergman on TV Jules Bergman
was my science editor of choice as a 13
year old
I watched ABC and Jules Bergman tell me
about the status of the mission and not
long after that I guess I became 14
years old and gave up the space program
for the things that suddenly attract the
attention of a your average 14 year old
none of which I'm ashamed of I'm happy
to say years go by and as I as I became
an actor I had just played the the
baseball player in the motion picture
league of their own which has gone down
in history is being known as that
Madonna film and after having had that
opportunity I was sitting around with my
crack team of show business experts the
two old ladies who work for me part time
and I do what do you want to do next I
mean if you could do anything what would
you want to do now I have to confess
that most American actors have what we
know as the big four we have four
different roles that we want to play we
we want to do any sort of a movie that
allows us to be a cowboy an army man a
baseball player and in fact an astronaut
I had played the baseball player so I
was searching around for one of the
remaining three items on the big four to
do and I pointed out to them that that
the story of Apollo 13 I thought then
years ago would make a fascinating story
because I I was aware of it my crack
team of show business experts says was
that's the one that landed on the moon
and I just know know that I explained
what the story was to them and we then
promptly decided to wait three years for
Jeff and Jim to get together and write
the book that we could base the movie on
from from from a pure moviemaking point
of view from the pure storytelling point
of view the great thing about the saga
of Apollo 13 is that there is nothing
that we could have made up that would
have been better than what Jim and Fred
and Jack and the people in Mission
Control actually went through it was as
those of you who have seen it even
though you know that Jim is here and so
it the the movie does have a happy
ending the the very happy ending I might
say as a matter of fact with this space
medal there's a sequel in it now that we
put together a continuing saga and I
don't think Kevin's available to play
Jim in the sequel so I still have a
chance because of the actual facts that
the his literally the historical record
we had a story that was unbelievably
fascinating and oddly enough brand-new a
joke that we had when we were making the
movie was you know we're telling a story
about people going to the moon we're
making a movie about a voyage around the
moon and it is a period piece
wherein we're driving old cars that have
horrible emission controls on them we're
wearing we're wearing fabrics that are
not found anywhere in nature and and
Kathleen Quinlan is Marilyn Lovell had
shades of color on her face that have
never been duplicated again as well as
hair and oh it was wild but that's
that's the great storytelling aspect of
Apollo 13 the the greater artistic
aspect of Apollo 13 the story the movie
I think is the presence of mr. Jim
Lovell the the irony of a man who even
when I was 13 years old and knew that
Jim had been around the moon once
already to me was what set it apart from
any other sort of movie of its ilk in
his other sort of adventure story and
made it something that would land in the
lap I think of every American any human
being that is seeing the movie for the
first time knowing that Jim has been
around the moon knowing that Jim Lovell
and Fred Hayes and Jack Swagger are
circling the moon on just one great big
arc of trajectory to hurl back to earth
like some sort of thrown hammer I think
is what makes it something that is oddly
approachable not just to us as human
beings but also to us as people who
understand the concepts of art it's a
it's a story that's told right out of
the Greeks it's equal to Ulysses on his
own individual Odyssey coming back
around and wondering just purely whether
or not we will get home I think I have
been a great I've been a very lucky band
because I've been able to benefit from
being an actor and being able to tell
the story to be able to take part in I'm
I love my job
I'll make movies about anything it's a
greatest job in the world it's way
better than what you people do for a
living
and could I get to I get to dress up and
pretend to be somebody else and pretend
to do great things I really feel that I
am very very fortunate and I think all
of us on the on the film bill paxton and
Kevin Bacon and Edie Harris all the
actors who were involved in the movie
Gary Sinise we all felt that it was an
honor to be playing these men and women
we felt it was a great privilege to be
able to be paid to do something to tell
the story that we think is so inspiring
and so hopeful and part of our
collective consciousness as Americans
and I I think was the luckiest of them
all because I got to play this guy who
for two weeks in the flight of jiminy
seven sat right next to Frank Borman
with tubes sticking out of his head and
things wrapped around his legs I could
only imagine that must have smelled
pretty bad in that little jiminy capsule
by the time it was done he got to sit in
the light to play a man who sat in the
left-hand seat on jiminy 12 and while
Buzz Aldrin was off making a flawless
evie a in outer space was able to tell
him to a check under the hood and wash
the windows while he was out there I got
to play one of the first three men who
left the Earth's planet gravitational
field visited and orbited the moon
literally the first three human beings
to go literally where no man has gone
before and I got to play the the
commander the guy in the left-hand seat
the man who was going to receive the
space congressional space middle von I
got to play mr. Jim Lovell Jim
thank you thank you Tom thank you thank
you thank you thank you Tom is a hard
act to follow let me put it that way I
recall was being with Ron hard one time
and Tom gave one of those nice talks and
and Ron said boy that guy can really
talk and Tom anytime that you want to
get out of the acting business and want
to be my press agent be my guest
let me let me begin my remarks by
somehow telling you exactly how this
whole project got started
naturally 25 years ago this incident
occurred when we got off the spacecraft
got on the carrier and Jack and Fred and
I looked at each other we dusted
ourselves off and we found out we were
still alive we said you know this would
make a very good story why don't we
write a book about it and we all vowed
that we'd get together and write a book
but you know the best intentions of
everybody jack eventually went into
politics Fred one of the aerospace
industry I got involved in telephones
and it wasn't until 1991 when I retired
and my secretary looked at me
I still had an office for a little bit
she said what are you gonna do and then
she said why don't you write that book
you've been telling me about all these
years and so I said fine but I said I'm
not a you know a a career author and 91
went 5 or than 92 I got a letter out of
the blue from a young man by the name of
Jeffrey Krueger he said I'm a writer for
the Discover Magazine written a lot of
articles never wrote a full length book
before thought that Apollo 13 would be a
good story and I wrote back I said yeah
I'd like to do the same thing let's go
off of this thing and so we did the got
started had an agent we produced a
little outline one chapter and outline
out of that our agent said it around
we've got a publisher boy I'm happy as a
clam now we got to start working on this
book unbeknownst to us a couple of
months later our agent sent it out to
California it was passed around a very
movies production companies
Ron Howard happened to see it and liked
it and I got a call from the agent I was
sitting down he said are you sitting
down and I said oh the publisher is
remaking there must be something in the
back of the contract and he says we just
sold an option to the movie industry
I said you gotta be kidding we haven't
written the book yet well to make a long
story short you know the option was
there we went out to talk to Ron and I
apologized Tom I really made a mistake
when I thought that Kevin Costner could
do the job because there is a closeted
astronaut right there and of course when
Tom came aboard the project that's when
the option turned into the real thing
now why is this movie so successful is
it because of Ron Howard's direction
certainly he had a lot to do with a
great director is that the actors that
portrayed it well you know Tom he did a
magnificent job and the other people did
just as well is it the special effects
yep there's lots of special effects
state of the art but there's a lot more
to this movie than just a movie I think
it reminds the audience when they go
into this movie of something that was
real something that was that they were
proud of as Americans the patriotic you
know fever in their in their bodies that
come up and they saw something that was
real life or crisis that had been
overcome due to the teamwork and the
motivation of a lot of people involved
and I think that is the real reason why
this movie has still been number one in
the movie houses and why everybody seems
to like it it appeals to all ages
you remember Sputnik a lot of you people
probably weren't born at that time 1957
I remember Sputnik the Russians tell me
put a missile up there or a satellite
and we were all saying to ourselves why
could we do that what's wrong with our
educational system and it turned out
into that chaos that NASA was formed and
all of a sudden for the next 30-some
years a lot of people looked up at NASA
had a sort of a role model a lot of
young people followed the career is due
to what NASA was doing in space I can
recall a lot of people coming to me in
the last few years after they had made
their careers and said you know it was
your flights or so-and-so's flights that
really got me to think about being a
doctor or being an airline pilot or
engineer so I really think that role
model was there and I can recall back in
61 when President Kennedy said we're
going to put a man on the moon and bring
him back safely
now I really believe that was more
political in nature than it was
technical but that brought forth a great
Drive of a lot of aerospace people and
by gosh we did it with five months to
spare but now those days was a time
where we had confrontation we had that
great evil empire out there which was in
some respects a lot of good competition
we don't have that any longer now it's
cooperation now we're working together
and the earth keeps getting smaller and
smaller and now we're into cooperation
in a joint venture an International
Space Station 14 countries are involved
and we have to work together we can't be
back up by ourselves anymore it's very
very important not just on a technical
point of view but really on a political
or a diplomatic point of view very very
important then of course on the domestic
scene the space efforts that we have
done really what I think is a creative
program obviously you all heard about
spin-offs there's a book about that
thick on them I don't have to mention
that the computer industry in the early
60s and 70s was really had a lot of
start from the seed money that NASA put
into it but it's built up and this
domestic program I think is very very
important because it creates new
industries industries that have nothing
to do with going into space do jobs and
of course new taxes so there is a return
on what we do in space but NASA itself
and the space efforts that we do is not
an end in itself it's a support function
it supports other people other
industries other government
organizations with data and and
materials and all sorts of things for
instance in space itself we have a
microgravity environment no convection
no gravity we can look at a lot of
things that can be done in space new
serums new
Krystal's for electronics industry we
have a vacuum that we can use a pure
vacuum if we have to we have the
unfiltered solar rays that can be
utilized there's lots of things we can
do and a temperature spectrum of over
400 degrees and of course in space we
can support not only the government
operations but the private sector
recovering satellites launching
satellites repairing satellites and then
of course looking back at the earth
getting that quicker return on our
investment by finding out more about the
earth all those things that affect the
earth today all the things that we're
worried about volcanism earthquakes the
El Nino pollution all those sort of
things so why is this movie so important
it's because it brings back to the
American public all those who see it all
those who read about it
a very important part of our history of
how we've faced a crisis and how we got
over that crisis with teamwork and
motivation and initiative thank you
alright I'm the mail sorter up here jim
lovell how do you respond to critics who
say that our space program now in its
just becoming a scholarship fund for the
russian program well let me put it this
way i think that the the idea of
cooperation with russia with the other
countries is very important they have a
lot of good technical capability over
there they don't have any money but a
lot of technical capability that
technical capability come in this
direction or you can go someplace else I
would rather have us working together in
a cooperation together because there's a
lot of potential in Russia and I don't
think that is a waste of money or just a
scholarship program for Tom Hanks say
you've played some memorable roles in
your career do you ever find that
reality and Hollywood tend to blur
together and will the RIC will the real
Tom Hanks please stand up
little man I make my living there I'm
probably the last guy to ask this
question oh I have played some very nice
parts I I think that the I think that
the only time that motion pictures can
be a true motor for social change is
when they somehow record the truth the
when they're honest about what's going
on in our lives I think that for the
vast in the vast overall picture movies
are a distraction from our daily lives
that's one of the reasons that we seek
them out you can call it entertainment
if you want to but the idea of going
into a room for two hours means that you
get to escape whatever it is you're
experiencing on the outside world that's
not a bad thing but that's not what the
true power of motion pictures or any art
really is the true power is when you
walk into a darkened theater and up on
the screen you actually see your own
live reflected back at you then it can
actually be some sort of instigator for
ourselves where we not only want to
emulate what we see up on the screen but
we realize that we can implement it in
our own daily lives I like to think that
that's some of the things that I try to
shoot for in Motion Pictures but then I
go off and make movies like Turner and
hooch and I wonder what the hell
for mr. Louisville what should NASA look
like in 20 years should we foot the bill
of a half trillion dollars or so to send
astronauts to Mars should we go back to
the moon or conversely should we rely
more on robotic missions and develop
less expensive goals no that's an
age-old question we have to balance what
we do in space we have to look at what
NASA does as a support function for
other entities that will help this
country a robotic exploration is cheaper
and it's very very important and NASA
has not abandoned that area they have
not abandoned the research in
aeronautics which of course was the
original NACA the but it's I think in
the future what we're going to see is
really really a concentration on the
space station looking back at the earth
as I mentioned before getting together
as a cooperative effort between
countries so that we can have a lot of
communication between countries that
spill over to other diplomatic means I
think we should keep the program going
there's no reason to drastically cut it
I can see where there could be some
infrastructure changes so that it
becomes more efficient every program
every agency that grows up becomes
inefficient and every once in a while
you have to cut it down and I'm sure
you've seen this in Washington and
spades but and I think the NASA could do
the same thing but the basic programs
the programs that make this country a
leader we should continue to fund in a
very progressive way not to go overboard
in any one area Thanks
for mr. Hanks what was the most
difficult aspect aspect of mr. lovell's
character for you to portray well of
course I was severely hampered by the
fact that it looked nothing like Kevin
Costner I had I had breakfast with with
with Jeff in New York City and he was
showing these stacks and stacks of
photographs of Jim and I hadn't really
seen a real clear photograph I what I
thought oh my god he looks just like
Kevin Costner
I think it actually was you can say the
most difficult it wasn't difficult it
was it was a joy every step of the way
well I wasn't when I was doing the you
know what what research you can and when
you're a big honkin movie star and
you're down in NASA
talking to people about what it was like
back then and mmm you've done son and
all the autographs and your picture
taken and you can actually get down to
brass tacks
I asked about I asked him so what can
you tell me about Jim Lovell and they
all said Jim was just the greatest guy
Jim and if you read and Michael Collins
books or Buzz Aldrin's books or any any
sort of record of the space agency
you'll find out that Jim was a great
pilot an incredibly fierce competitor
but also a guy that system trouble
rolled right off his back they seemed to
be able to love truly what he was doing
when I heard that I said well you know
what I'm the perfect guy to play Jim
for mr. Louisville in the movie the crew
was greatly relieved to learn that Ken
Mattingly was working on the fuel
problem in the simulator but in the book
the problem seems to have been solved by
Jon Arryn and Arnie Aldrich what's the
story you know I always get these
serious questions there's Tom Tom Tom
kid although you know the soft-shoe
stuff I'm gonna be an actor Tom that's
what I'm gonna do yeah well seriously
you know when you when you have a book
you have the ability to expand out and
really through things in detail because
the reader can take his time going
through it when you're making a movie
and the first rough-cut from what Ron
Howard was telling me that after he
threw away all the film he didn't really
want kept at all it was about a four
hour movie and consequently Universal
said there's no way we're gonna have a
four hour movie or even a three hour
movie and had to keep cutting it cutting
it down there are some things that had
to be concentrated in the film that
actually did not occur or did occur in
more in more expansive mode and the real
things many people contributed to all
the solutions to the problems we had in
the movie of course we see Kent manually
doing a lot of the work because he was
really a composite character in certain
aspects of a lot of people that were
doing work feeding and information so
that we could get the re-entry the
program down pat and everything else and
that is the artistic license without
taking away from the real meaning of the
movie or the purpose of it or the the
ending which of course fortunately was
very very good
some critics of the movie say that it is
too technical and ignores the
metaphysical or spiritual mr. Lovell and
mr. Hanks how much did you and your crew
think about the meaning of life and
death on that mission first when you
were in the mission and then when you
were portraying him in the mission
let me handle that very serious question
I think that the metaphysical and
spiritual aspects of the story are
inherent to the idea in the first place
one of the things I'm most proud of of
the movie is the launch sequence because
it starts with naked men these little
pink beings that are getting the hair
shaved off of our chests and alcohol put
on so the biosensors could be attached
and by the time they are floating up in
the free fall of outer space we realize
that that's flesh and blood and brain
and marrow that is inside those pressure
suits and inside the steel Hall of the
of the spaceship honesty I think that
the spiritual and metaphysical aspects
of the movie are inherent in moments
when in the first scene of the film Jim
Lovell is in his backyard covering up
the moon with his thumb and in the
latter moments of the movie he is
circling the the moon and covering up
the earth with his son did I say that
right with this thumb I think that if
without making a cinderblock house out
of the spiritual aspects of the movie I
think it's in there and I think it's one
of the life blobs of the life Bloods of
the film and I think that's also one of
the reasons that people are still going
to see it here in late July that's why
tom is a great actor because he picked
up a little thing that I had talked
about many many times and that was the
use of the thumb you saw that in the
movie
when I was not around the moon on Apollo
8 you know I could put my thumb up to
the window I could completely hide the
earth behind my thumb and realize that
everything in life is really relative
everything that I have knew knew down
here all my loved ones the country the
problems the whole world that was behind
my thumb
if you have to think about that for a
while and it is it is it is quite a
feeling because it really gives you it
really gives you a humble feeling one of
really insignificance one of looking
back at the earth and saying everything
I've ever known I've got to get back
there it's a spacecraft just like the
one I'm on about four or five billion
astronauts down there all trying to find
the same things from life and you know
limited resources and everything is
behind my thumb
for mr. Hanks a will there be a sequel
to Forrest Gump will you be in the
sequel and could you please answer the
questions talking like Forrest Gump
I'll answer the second question first
Forrest Gump has been the only retired
in those moments except in my house when
I find he must make a reappearance and
it's usually someone you need to go to
bed let me you know it took us it took
nine years to figure out how to make the
first Forrest Gump I think to slam
together a second story just in order to
cash in on its popularity phenomenon
would be a cheat and I don't think
anybody would like the result the studio
would love the opening weekends grosses
but in the end result I think that we
would diminish the the true impact of
what I think is a magical kind of story
so maybe there will be a sequel sometime
before the I guess it's the year 2004
they look for it then several members of
the audience asked whether you and Ron
Howard Howard will be testifying on
Capitol Hill in behalf of a larger NASA
budget boy you know as public figures
guys like Ron and myself are constantly
asked to go and speak about things like
that I have been asked to go appear
before the who are those people up there
the Congress Lord knows that we we will
we take the official position that we
believe in the space program and and we
don't want to see any funding cut we we
view this as being the space program I
think is the best example of us all we
stole as a matter of fact we would sit
around and and philosophize about the
space program talk about how we missed
the loot the Apollo program and as we
were rhapsodize about it we would lay
these ideas into the movie there's a
speech that Jim Lovell gives in the the
VAB to visiting senator and congressman
and that whole rap that we talk about
computers the size of a room that can
hold millions of pieces of information
and how it's the best part of us all and
what did the man say give me a lever and
I can move the world and what would
happen if Christopher Columbus
returned from the new world and no one
had and no one followed back in his
footsteps all that stuff comes from what
Ron and I and I think a great majority
of the the filmmakers felt about the
space program would we go and testify
well I think that would make some really
great video for all the news gathering
organizations I don't know what we could
say beyond our efforts in the motion
picture itself I think that's a very a
much better statement that we could do
sitting than sitting in front of that oh
those those table those tables with the
green tablecloths and those three
microphones sitting out there be a very
intimidating moment we would probably
consider it whether it would do any good
or not I think would be questioned I
think the the great statement that
anybody on the filmmaking side could
could make about funding for NASA is is
wrapped up in the 210 minutes or so of
that's a little movie called Apollo 13
commander the Lovell could you elaborate
on the role that to Canadians dr. French
and dr. Oetken of the University of
Toronto played in getting Apollo 13 back
to earth
I have nothing to say about that I would
like to know how they played a role I
would have included in the in the movie
Jeff do you know about these two we must
have missed it in our research I'm sorry
to hear about that but I'm sorry but I
have no no comment
question for mrs. Louisville
did you ever get your wedding ring back
it was a naval academy miniature and it
did not completely go down the drain but
it did come off
this question on your performance in the
movie Philadelphia was a difficult
career decision to play the part of the
gay character in the movie and did you
hear from gay organizations about your
foot trail it wasn't difficult at all I
thought it was an amazing part what I
had said earlier about the desire that
possibility that the motion pictures can
reflect our lives right back at us was
part and parcel to the whole concept
behind the motion picture Philadelphia
and neither I nor any of my associates
batted an eye in regards to taking the
part we were given a lot of credit I
think for being bold and and courageous
in in putting my playing a and E back
hit and I don't understand where it
comes from to me it's the simplest thing
in the world what did the gay community
was pretty much split into thirds in
regards not just in my performance but
the movie as a whole one-third of the
gay community I would say was incredibly
enthusiastic and very pleased at our
efforts another third said thank you
very much and one third said this is not
us and this is not our lives and you're
not representing us at all none of us I
think we're surprised by the end result
we were dealing with a very very
volatile aspect of the American cultural
fabric right now and I think everybody
involved and I can say for myself that
I'm greatly pleased and very very
honored to have been a part of the first
mainstream
big-budget American motion picture to
deal with the subject matter and there's
many there's a zillion more stories out
there that deserve to be brought to the
light of day on celluloid for audiences
to see thank you
some of nasa's self-described dweebs
have distributed a list of top 10 errors
in apollo 13 film including the
astronauts looking at their landing site
and the sea of tranquillity while they
were on the dark side of the moon were
you aware of the mistakes does it matter
you sit down
hold on the Dark Side of the Moon
sometimes is completely illuminated by
the light of the Sun we just the far
side of the Moon is a better way of
putting it it's not always dark in the
motion picture we come around through
the dark wedge that is the moon and the
the landing first of all we pass over a
tranquility place first and then later
on we pass over from our gym did you
pass over from our when you were coming
around the far sideline see now there
you go so the the dweebs are correcting
a lot of other the inaccuracies in the
film and you know I'm mad about him too
but I did I think that for ever in a
scene if there's any given in accuracy
there are at least two accuracy so I
think we're batting pretty well
when my wife and I went to see the movie
the other night in preparation for this
your appearance as a young boy sitting
next to me and he turned to his mother
and he said oh now I know why Apollo 13
had so much trouble Forrest Gump was in
charge
all right for mr. Louisville what aspect
of your character do you think that mr.
Hanks got down most accurately and what
the what do the myths about you in his
portrayal
well when Tom first came aboard we met
down at Johnson Space Center and Tom
said you know I'd like to learn a little
about your character because I'm gonna
play your part I have to see you know
just how you act your mannerisms and
things like that and so I invited him
down to to the house and and we came on
down and and I first of all I picked him
up in Austin and I put him in my
airplane now I don't know how much
flying he's done in very small airplanes
but we went along and of course flying
and and I was an old test pilot so I
thought of course but 20-some years ago
I said first of all Tom's gonna learn
how to be a test pilot and an astronaut
you know and a naval officer so I
started doing all those things that I
can remember back in tests and airplanes
and and finally I said Tom I said you
know now if we if we're lucky we'll be
able to get that NASA's zero-g airplane
and and really get some zero-g and I
said you know so stand by so I try to
put this little plane in in zero-g and
he just stood there or sat there you
know and yeah everything is fine so the
first first thing I saw that his
characteristics like me was the fact
that he hung in there he stayed around a
debt to do the job right and as a matter
of fact when I was there I said Tom
didn't you do another movie he had just
finished Philadelphia and I thought I
haven't seen Philadelphia and he said
yeah I said what was the name of that
movie he hadn't Bonacci and he said Gump
I said Gump
he said yeah Forrest Gump I said Tom
what's that movie about and he said well
it's about a guy was sort of limited
mental capability you know that goes
around and but finds that goes and sees
sees the president's and sees everything
he just leaves a very good life I said
oh I said let's see a Philadelphia Gale
or you know and Forrest Gump limited
mental capability now I get it make him
to be a test pilot or an astronaut but
he did a great job his characteristics
his mannerisms that I think of course
I'm prejudiced because I'm so close to
it he picked him up very subtly he
picked him up and he did a very very
good job in it
I'm actually sorry that there weren't
any bonafide airplane flying scenes in
the movie because then I could have done
a really good imitation of Jim Lovell
flying a plane your your concept of a
guy flying the plane is usually this
here's a guy flying the plane
that's that's what you would think how
jim lovell flies a plane this is how Jim
flies a plane
I knew that I was dealing with a guy who
is very comfortable behind the wheel
because Jim there was a he flies through
the clouds
you know usually it easy to go around
the clay he's just there's a big cloud
and so that I wish I could have done a
true a true scene where I could have
actually been the whole physical
presence
mr. Hanks you're so funny as yourself
forget kevin costner why don't you make
a movie where you are yourself for two
hours for the early part of my career I
made about six films in which I played
myself for two
I'll put mr. Louisville just to bring us
up to date a postscript on the film did
Fred Hayes and his wife have a boy or
girl they didn't tell us and secondly in
the movie you didn't want to have
swagger with you on the on the mission
did you really not want him with you
no that's a very good question actually
first of all Fred Hayes had a boy so
we'll get that all the way
second of all Jack's like it was a very
competent pilot in just four days
we retrained very long days when we
found out that Manley was a bachelor and
there was no doubt he was going to come
down with the measles which of course
never occurred but Jack came aboard we
really intrude did not have any qualms
about his capability of being one of the
crew one of the things that we had to
train for though before we took off was
the time when he was by himself orbiting
the moon we are coming up from the moon
and with Ken Manatee we even got to know
the inflections of his voice exactly
what he was doing what he was thinking
so that we could make the rendezvous
with a little trouble we had not trained
with Jack for a long time as a matter of
fact a lot of things that movie are true
one of them was the fact that we gave
Jack that the the duties to get the
hotel rooms and take care of the guest
list and things like that but when he
came aboard it was he was one of the
crew now in the movie we try to portray
it so that so that he really earns his
wings as he goes along there's a little
bit of doubt you know his docking but as
he goes along he becomes more and more
confident and then if you recall at the
end of the movie you know Jim slips in
the commander's seat like he's used to
it and then something he realized that
no he's not the command module pilot
this Weikart is swipers job is to bring
the spacecraft back through the
atmosphere for the entry and and he is
one of the one of the crew
before we get to the final before we get
to the final question I have a few gifts
here for you all first of all
commend the level certificate of
appreciation well thank you for being
with us and a famous Press Club and
month oh there we go to keep keep you
awake unleashes to the moon and
elsewhere Tom Hanks you get the same
equal time certificate of appreciation
one Press Club mug movie then we have
the whole something else I have here
what is this oh yes
live gift for someone else this is a
famous National Press Club t-shirt guess
who's going to get it :
and finally for you miss Louisville for
standing up to my surprise question
well throw whatever you call it blanket
or throw or something like that so now
the final question is supposed to be a
humdinger
we'll try very very hard either or both
of you can answer this one which is the
greater honor appearing at the National
Press Club being cited by the President
of the United States or immortalized by
Roy Rogers restaurant with the Apollo 13
bacon cheeseburger combo
well I got another I get all these
difficult questions the president
citation was a complete surprise to me
what I arrived last night in Washington
DC naturally I was looking forward to
the Press Club I had been here before I
introduced at that time Vice President
Gerald Ford and I can recall quite
vividly The Secret Service said now look
at now you tell everybody to stay seated
until we get the vice president out of
here and I said very well I got up to
tell everybody to stay seated while the
Vice President left and the vice
president said no you're not I'm going
down and talking to all these people so
I but no I I enjoy very much coming to
the Press Club and of course the
president's meeting a little bit later
on this afternoon is something which is
surprise but of course I'm very much
looking forward to that too
Thanks
I want to thank you all and both of you
for being here and members of the
audience for attending I ask all of you
to please sit in your seats for about
two minutes well our two guests get out
they do have to go over to the white
house shortly so they'll scoot out and
please sit and thank you very much